today there are a dozen companies with a
market cap above 500 billion dollars
most of which are tech companies but
none of these companies were actually
the first company to reach the 500
billion mark the first company to reach
this milestone was actually cisco way
back in 2000 at the peak of the dot-com
bubble this made cisco the most valuable
company in the world but after the
dot-com bubble burst cisco lost 77
percent of its value and it has never
recovered to its former peaks looking at
the stock graph it looks like cisco has
been making positive progress but this
is actually rather deceiving you see
cisco has been aggressively buying back
their stock over the past 20 years so
the stock has to reach much higher
levels for the company to be worth the
same amount currently the price to beat
is 118 dollars meaning that cisco has to
rally nearly 100 percent just to beat
its dot-com peak so here's how cisco
became the world's most valued company
and her fall from grace
taking a look back the story of cisco
dates back to a stanford couple named
sandy lerner and leonard bosack sandy
was the director of computer facilities
and leonard was in charge of managing
the computers throughout the early 1980s
stanford students and staff commonly
used something called the blue box to
link all the computers in the school the
blue box was designed in-house by andy
bechtosheim and william yeager and he
developed the circuitry while william
developed the software the blue box was
just a simple multi-protocol router but
40 years ago this was some pretty
advanced tech with significant
commercial potential however william did
not want to sell the blue box
commercially and andy had already
co-founded sun microsystems so sandy and
leonard decided to commercialize a
product themselves and with that the duo
launched cisco on december 10 1984. the
name cisco was a reference to san
francisco and the logo is of course the
golden gate bridge despite the quick
start the early days were not smooth by
any means you see it neither stanford
nor william were happy to hear that
these two had stolen their technology
and were trying to profit from it
william claims that he never gave
permission to sell the technology
commercially and stanford contemplated
five criminal charges against cisco for
intellectual property theft for years
but eventually the two parties would
meet in the middle and stanford would
agree to license the technology to cisco
in 1987. with stanford on their side the
couple could freely sell the router
which was extremely lucrative by the end
of 1987 cisco was selling 250 000 worth
of routers every month but the couple
had a much larger vision for the company
so they partnered with venture
capitalist don valentine and sekia
capital during this funding round though
the couple lost majority control of the
company and this was the beginning of
the end for the duo
well quite simply i got fired sooner or
later the venture capitalists always
want to get rid of the founders
that's just part of don's formula don
valentine brought in a new ceo named
john morgridge and this guy did not get
along with the founders at all
first of all he went ahead and replaced
several of the managers at cisco many of
whom were friends with the founders and
after cisco went public in february of
1990 he went ahead and fired sandy
herself leonard would instantly resign
from cisco in protest but this didn't
really accomplish anything the couple
ended up selling all their stock for 100
million dollars and to put that in
perspective their 30 stake would have
been worth 150 billion dollars at the
peak of the bubble
so yeah sandy and leonard got screwed
over but in a way it's actually quite
poetic the couple stole the technology
from stanford and the vc stole the
company from them
though the founders were completely out
this wasn't a bad thing by any means
while john morgridge had a lot of beef
with the founders he knew exactly how to
grow the company at first john targeted
corporate clients with large scientific
departments cisco offered to unify their
science departments by linking all of
their tech together
around the same time local area networks
or lands were blowing up in popularity
and cisco became one of the go-to
companies for setting up and the linking
lands between 1991 and 1992 cisco sales
nearly doubled from 183.2 million
dollars to 339.6 million dollars
similarly their net profit jumped from
43.2 million dollars to 84.4 million
dollars this explosive growth won cisco
the title of second fastest growing
company in the us but it didn't take
long for mainstream competitors to enter
the scene with the biggest one being ibm
you see ibm had been growing their own
network business for years called system
network architecture or sna
sna was a proprietary network that was
specific to ibm computers and given that
sna was limited to ibm computers cisco
more or less ignored the network but in
september of 1992 ibm announced that
they were going to license their
peer-to-peer networking protocol used in
sna
cisco instantly fired back claiming that
they were going to modify their own
peer-to-peer networking protocol so that
it can be used with sna
despite this fiery start though cisco
gave in within just 12 months and ended
up helping ibm develop and license the
protocol
aside from cooperating with ibm cisco
decided to partner with atnt as well
in 1993 we saw the emergence of a new
data communications protocol called atm
or asynchronous transfer mode
atm allowed for high speed transfers of
data voice video and images without the
use of routers instead of finding the
new technology and embracing routers
cisco decided to enter a joint
development project with atnta and
stratacom together they developed the
standards for the new technology and
ensured that it could be used with
existing networks these high-level
partnerships combined with the rapidly
growing network space allowed cisco to
continue flying high throughout the
1990s by 1998 cisco crossed the 100
billion mark in market cap and in 1999
they would go on an acquisition spree
they bought a total of 17 companies that
year with valuations as high as 6.9
billion dollars
it seemed like a trillion evaluation was
just around the corner but then the
dot-com bubble burst and that marked the
end of cisco's domination
though cisco's stock price plummeted the
executives were still quite optimistic
about the future after all it's not like
the crash was specific to cisco so cisco
turned their focus onto new avenues for
growth which led them to the consumer
space back in the early 1990s regular
consumers had basically no need for
routers and network devices but with
rapid internet adoption everyday
consumers were quickly becoming a larger
part of the picture so in 2003 cisco
spent 500 million dollars to acquire the
consumer router and the network company
linksys soon after they launched their
human networking advertising campaign
this campaign basically marketed cisco's
vision of not just linking together
technology but linking together humans
from around the world
it's not really clear how effective the
campaign was at increasing sales but
glancing at the comments it looks like
people really like the music they used
in the ads
anyway aside from targeting everyday
consumers cisco also looked for new ways
they could target corporate customers
they had already linked together
infrastructure so the next natural step
was to link together people and that
brings us to the webex acquisition in
march of 2007 cisco acquired webex for
3.2 billion dollars and this got cisco
into the web conferencing space on top
of all this cisco was also trying to
expand into emerging markets for example
cisco spent one billion dollars to
establish globalization center east in
bangalore india they also purchased
several companies from emerging markets
such as darned networks despite all
their efforts though cisco hasn't really
gone anywhere in a long time
if you look at their revenue graph it
hasn't moved in a decade and their net
income graph doesn't paint a better
picture either so what happened
one of the biggest factors holding back
cisco is being spread too then
throughout the early 2000s cisco
constantly focused on expanding into new
sectors and industries but they didn't
execute any of these particularly well
for example remember how cisco bought
lynxes for 500 million in 2003 well they
sold it to belkin in 2013. the
acquisition amount was not revealed but
it likely wasn't a favorable for cisco
similarly the webex acquisition didn't
go too well either cisco's vice
president of engineering eric yuan
suggested transforming webex into a
mobile friendly video system and given
that eric was one of webex's first 20
employees and knew the industry inside
and out it probably would have been a
good idea to listen to him but instead
cisco rejected his idea and eric ended
up quitting and founding zoom as you can
see it's not like cisco was entering bad
industries in fact they were entering
great industries but they weren't
executing well in any industry which
made it easier for competitors to
overtake them speaking of competitors we
have cisco's second shortfall which is
market saturation one of the keys to
cisco's fast growth was that there was
very little competition in the 80s and
90s but now the server router and
networking markets are extremely
saturated basically every tech company
you can think of has their own server
business whether that be netgear dell
huawei or lenovo this increased
competition has made it much more
difficult to secure market share and
shine above the rest but by far the
biggest problem with cisco is that their
core business is losing relevance
historically the core of cisco has been
selling networking hardware to corporate
customers but many corporate customers
no longer need cisco's hardware instead
of buying hardware from cisco and using
the hardware to offer cloud and service
solutions corporate customers are just
building their own hardware companies
like google amazon and microsoft have no
desire to rely on cisco for hardware now
it's not like they've caught all
relationships with cisco but with time
they're becoming more and more
independent and unless cisco finds a new
way to appeal to these customers it
won't take long for this stagnation to
turn into a decline
despite all these shortfalls and lack of
growth cisco is still one of the biggest
companies in the world currently they
hover around the low 30s on the fortune
500 list with a market cap of 250
billion dollars looking forward while
cisco's networking future isn't so clear
many cisco investors argue that cisco is
no longer a networking company even
though a majority of cisco's revenue
still comes from providing
infrastructure cisco investors argue
that what's more important is where
cisco is investing their money and the
vast majority of cisco's investments
today are in services applications and
security whether these investments will
actually pan out is yet to be seen but
even if they don't cisco is by no means
in danger of collapsing they're still
extremely profitable and it would take
decades for such a company to fall but
if your shift away from networking
doesn't work out it becomes more and
more unlikely that cisco will ever
return to their former glory but that's
just what i think do you guys think
cisco can make a comeback to the top 5
or top 10 companies in the world comment
that down below
also drop a like if you're glad that you
didn't buy cisco stock in 2000
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
more questions logically answered but
until then i'm ari and i'll see you guys
on the next one
you